well  it's getting very dangerous here we're  approaching sorry  very different the nakamura game we're  approaching the end of the game wow he  didn't take the pawn  he's  still entertaining us  [Laughter]  well  yeah because now it's a trend to play it  all out until two kings on the board  right yeah but he could have taken the  three pawn he didn't he wants to finish  a night up  or the moral victory maybe it could be a  bet or something that he will have extra  night  yeah  well what a long game nearly 100 moves  just 96 moves  that's the power move not to take  not to take the porn to insist on this  so the last game is there running a  little bit differently than we expected  just  five moves ago let's say  but